as with most major Marvel movies a fan
speculation surrounding the latest
upcoming spider-man see callers been
running rampant with both plausible and
downright bizarre theories and
predictions here are some of the
craziest fun theories we found that try
and predict the events in spider-man far
from home homelands new manager plays a
cryptic role of Dimitri and far from
home while the specific details of a
just role are still being kept under
wraps
fans of Marvel Comics were quick to
point out that his character shares a
name of the notorious spider-man fo the
beetrice mere jerk-off aka the chameleon
in a recent interview with comic-book
comm director Jon Watts was asked
point-blank whether or not a jazz
character was in fact the chameleon and
his answer was purposefully unclear
well Dimitri in the film works for Nick
Fury and I think anyone who works for
Nick Fury
they certainly have a mysterious past
we're not specifically saying that he's
but we're not not saying given that
spider-man homecoming included the
vulture the tinkerer the Prowler two
shockers and even a brief glimpse of
scorpion it's not hard to imagine that
far from home will also feature
appearances from multiple villains from
Spidey's notorious rogues gallery if the
me tree doesn't fact turn out to be the
chameleon it will add an engaging
element of mystery to the sequel leaving
audience guessing who's really who
speaking of which the Nick Fury showed
in the far from home trailers actually
be the chameleon in disguise
this theory seemingly stems from the
fact that in the comics the chameleon
started out as a Soviet spy with unique
abilities given a far from home takes
place in Europe
chameleons foreign origin could match up
quite nicely Nerdist takes this theory
one step further stating the Fury's
wardrobe in the far from home trailer
seems a little suspect in the footage
Florie done the same longer black trench
coat he wore way back in the early
phases of the MCU like in the first
Avengers film before shield was
deconstructed this is a stark contrast
to Fury's apparel and post shield
appearances in which he has worn more
discreet outfits this fashion faux-pas
could be proof that this isn't the real
Nick Fury who presumably through all is
called trench coats into the trash this
potential shocker could be the major
twist at some Holland T's when Screen
Rant visited the far from home set last
year when he said there's a scene in
this film where audiences will feel like
they were punched in the face even
filming it I remember walking
Alton than watching it again on the
monitors and asking John watts are you
sure that's okay
and he's like no it's not people are
going to hate the scene but what if the
chameleon is fury twist isn't coming
what are some other swerves far from a
homer might pull on an unsuspecting
audience one of the wildest fun theories
concerning the new Spidey flick is that
will learn that MJ Peters new love
interest is actually the daughter of
Nick Fury possible sure plausible yeah
we do know that fury mentioned having
had a wife in Captain America the Winter
Soldier my wife didn't know you were
married of course and that scene fury is
on the run from Hydra so while he said
he's a family man there's no way to know
if he's ever even kissed a girl let
alone out a wife or daughter over all
this one seems pretty unlikely
speaking of unlikely in the comics Ned
leaves as a Daily Bugle reporter who
undergoes a brief stint as a
supervillain Hobgoblin after being
brainwashed by Roderick Kingsley the
actual man behind the mask
although the MCU stead leads has more
similar to Gong Kaylie a comics obsessed
the best friend of Miles Morales says
spider-man the name alone is enough for
some fans were predicted a dark turn for
Ned him far from home did Ned switch to
super villainy be the big twist awaiting
moviegoers well the real issue of this
theory is that the Green Goblin hasn't
yet been introduced to the MCU and
without first introducing that villain
how would introducing the dollar store
version make any sense
then again while we're on the subject of
the Green Goblin in spider-man
homecoming and we learn that Tony Stark
had sold Avengers Tower and was on the
process of completely moving or the
team's various super props to their
Upstate facility and surprisingly a sale
of that magnitude made fans perk up
their ears prompting discussions about
the potential purchaser of the New York
Eye Royce additionally in the trailer
for far from home eagle-eyed viewers
notice how Spidey swings past what
appears to be the old stark tower only
now it's under construction so who could
the new owner or owners be in the comic
books
Norman Osborn briefly took over the
Avengers recruiting suspect characters
to the team including moonstone bullseye
and venom while donning the iron Patriot
armor the team better known as the Dark
Avengers took up residence in Avengers
tower in what would be a crazy twist
fans of the MCU have been theorizing
that are so far non-existent MCU version
of Norman Osborn is a buyer alluded to
in spider-man home come
making him at the future owner of
Avengers tower one of the more popular
theories gaining traction on line is the
Osborne's reveal will take place and one
afar from Holmes to end credits scenes
the theory originally posted by reddit
sir who claims to be a special-effects
artist for Disney posits that not only
will the scene reveal that Osborne is in
fact the new owner of Avengers tower now
proudly showcasing Oscorp where the a
once was but also confirm the rise of
the sinister six a team consisting of
Mysterio chameleon shocker vulture
scorpion and Osborne's own alter-ego the
Green Goblin this would certainly get
fans excited for the third solo
spider-man film which Tom Holland
previously confirms back in 2017
although this would certainly be a
satisfying reveal there's more than one
famous tower in Marvel Comics version of
New York City with Disney's
multi-billion dollar acquisition of 21st
Century Fox finally completed the other
logical prediction is our Avengers tower
could soon become the Baxter building
home to the Fantastic Four whose movie
rights were also returned to Disney
Marvel and the deal if this theory is
indeed true it would pave the way for
the likes of mr. fantastic Invisible
Woman a thing and the Human Torch to
finally make their longer way to return
to the MCU and suits up alongside the
remaining heroes one of the most
exciting fan theories about far from
home is that the x-men will somehow be
introduced to the MCU a beer a parallel
universe in the far from home trailer
Nick Fury explains the pizza parka that
Mysterio is from another dimension
inadvertently brought to the earth as a
result of Iron Man's life sacrificing
snap in Avengers end game Nick is from
Earth just not house a snapped or hole
in our dimension if Mysterio is indeed
telling the truth about his origin he's
living proof that there is a multiverse
in the MCU parallel universes and
interdimensional travel would be some
smart ways for Marvel Studios to
introduce their new toys so they're
already overflowing some box and it
worked and spider-man into the spider
verse that said we're talking about
Mysterio here a super villainous master
of manipulation and deception if
internet sloughs really want to theorize
as presence here is somehow proof that
the x-men are coming through the
dimensional divide as well that they
should probably crack a comic book or to
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more loop of videos about
the MCU are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the bail so you
don't miss a single
one
[Music]